et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
hervé marseille bonjour merci bonjour va
être avec vous êtes sénateur des
hauts-de-seine vous présidez le groupe
union centriste
ici au sénat on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par christine
bertrand de contrer à des pages blanches
and aliens dont je rêvais mars à jour
maire de marseille on va commencer par
ce qui fait la une de la grande majorité
de nos quotidiens régionaux ce matin
c'est la remise de ce rapport sauvé la
commission sauvé sur les abus sexuels
pratiqués au sein de l'église qui a donc
rendu ses conclusions deux cent seize
mille victimes 3000 religieux pédophiles
depuis les années 50 comment vous avez
réalisé face à cet essai c'est quelque
chose à un mauvais moment pour l'église
et pour la communauté chrétienne mais je
crois qu'il fallait en passer par là
après des années d'omerta voire de dénis
il faut saluer ce qu'a fait l'église
c'est à dire qu'elle est
la plongée la faire si je puis dire en
confiant cette mission à monsieur sauvé
qui est un grand commis de l'état qui
est un homme de qualité qui a fait le
travail et aujourd'hui à l'église parle
de honte bien sûr c'est la moindre des
choses de pardon mais ça suffit pas je
crois que maintenant il y aura
certainement un volet judiciaire puisque
qui aura des plaintes de déposées il y
en a déjà et puis il faudra que l'église
se réforme il faut surtout qu'elle tire
les conséquences de cette situation
tragique dramatique
énorme parler de chiffres uniquement
l'église
je crois pas je crois je crois je crois
que ça regarde l'église on parle de
laïcité
l'état ne peut pas s'ingérer dans les
affaires de l'église test à d'église de
se réformer de mettre des barrières de
fer l'introspection nécessaire il faut
aller jusqu'au bout des choses
la partie judiciaire elle elle existera
mais j'en ai plein
il ya trois ans sur l'ampleur de ce
phénomène a été refusé par la majorité
aujourd'hui pour le regretté devant ces
chiffres non je pense que le travail a
été fait par monsieur sauver et ceux qui
l'entourent je pense que parlementaire
non c'est la preuve c'est que l'église
l'a fait
l'église va se réformer le pape
intervient et je crois qu'il ya une
mission d'information qui avait été
engagée elle se poursuivra en tous les
cas c'est le souhait que nous avons
formulées et il y aura une audition de
monsieur sauver des responsables de
l'église et je crois qu'il faut que
cette mission d'information continue son
travail
on va parler
les prix de l'énergie augmentent et
grèves de plus en plus le pouvoir
d'achat des français hier jean castex
annoncé qu'ils pourraient agir sur le
levier fiscal en cas de nécessité est ce
que ça vous paraît suffisant
c'est à ça n'est jamais qu'un report des
échéances je crois qu'il ya des
élections présidentielles d'après ce que
j'ai compris
autour du mois de mai donc on va les
enjeux
je veux dire le premier ministre dit
attendez vous à savoir tout ça va
baisser
vers le mois d'avril on sait pas trop ce
qu il a dû voir ça cartomancienne
chinoise donc il dit ça va baisser et
donc on va enjamber les présidentielles
et puis on verra après on va lisser les
les coûts mais on voit bien que les
producteurs d'énergie eux ils
réfléchissent différemment ils disent
tant d c'est pas c'est pas à nous de
supporter cette affaire donc il aurait
fallu faire sinon
il aurait fallu déjà anticipé parce que
c'est une affaire quand même qu'on voit
venir depuis un certain temps puis si
vous arrivez à me dire aujourd'hui
quelle est la politique énergétique de
la france ça m'intéresse parce que on a
essayé de comprendre pour l'instant on
sait pas quelle est la politique
énergétique on ferme fessenheim et on va
refaire des petits ep r ici et là on
serait une bonne idée mais petit
personnage ça ça coûte très cher et à
côté de ça on va faire dde p r bon
nous nous défendons l'énergie atomique
c'est une énergie propre
c'est un des rares à tous que la france
a en matière industrielle
on a une des énergies les moins et les
moins coûteuses d'europe en ami saab a
aujourd'hui on dit on va faire des
énergies alternatives de l'éolien mais
comment il n'ya pas du vent tous les
jours faut bien faire autre chose à côté
donc tout ça coûte horriblement cher ça
prend du temps et on voit bien la
situation dans laquelle on est c'est à
dire
bien sûr bien sûr et on voit bien
l'embarras
du gouvernement regardez ce qui s'est
passé en allemagne madame merkel pour
répondre aux verts a stoppé aussi
l'énergie atomique et puis maintenant on
en est au charbon c'est à dire que c'est
c'est pas très écologique à le charbon
au delà tous à ce que vous pensez que le
pouvoir d'achat sera une des grandes
problématiques de la campagne qui
s'annonce absolument parce qu'on voit
bien que les françaises et les français
qui ont subi la pandémie qui ont été
amenés à ne plus travailler ou à moins
travailler pendant cette période et bien
reprennent leurs activités en
considérant que ça peut pas se faire de
la même façon et notamment dans les
services on voit bien dans l'hôtellerie
et on voit bien qu'il ya un problème de
rénumération surtout quand on voit la
part de l'énergie dans les
revenus des français les moins
j'allais dire payer
ça comment faire pour booster le feu le
pouvoir d'achat mais va falloir que dans
les entreprises il y ait des
concertations et on voit bien lui par
exemple dans la restauration qui propose
déjà des augmentations il faut qu'ils
aient de la concertation
faire des propositions va faire des
propositions mais ne peut pas venir de
l'état je vais dire ça se passe aussi
entre les employeurs et les salariés
faut qu'ils aient des concertations et
qu'on voit les progressions possible
là on voit bien qu'il ya un problème de
ressenti mais je veux dire si on est
lucide et honnête on considère on pourra
constater qu'il ya eu des augmentations
de pouvoir d'achat depuis plusieurs
années et a eu incontestablement une
augmentation du pouvoir d'achat mais le
ressenti des français notamment dans les
services c'est que le compte n'y est pas
et il considère qu'il faut des
augmentations salariales donc à partir
de là il faut engager des concertations
entre le patronat et par branches et les
salariés pour voir comment tout ça peut
évoluer autre sujet la réforme des
retraites edouard philippe est
intervenue la semaine dernière pour dire
qu' il fallait repousser l'âge de départ
à la retraite peut-être à 60 166 voire
67 ans qu'est ce que vous en pensez oui
sauf qu'il est un peu tard je suis dire
ce quinquennat et il finit bizarrement
quoi sert quand on profite d'être à
quelques mois des présidentielles pour
dire on va faire les états généraux de
la justice on va parler retraite pendant
les soldes les affaires continuent et
donc on est en train de prévoir l'avenir
seulement la fin du quinquennat il parle
du prochain quinquennat dit que ça doit
être la première réforme du prochain il
va falloir passer l'âge de départ à 65
66 ou 67 ans oui avec ça on sait très
bien qu'il faut faire quelque chose
nous nous sur le paramétrique ya pas eu
de soucis on l'a votée au sénat depuis
plusieurs années simplement à un moment
donné il faut faire quelque chose mais
c'est pas le moment il aurait fallu
faire ça avant on fera des propositions
là aussi dans le plfss mais c'est pas à
quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle
on peut entamer des débats mais
les nouvelles propositions
qu'est-ce qu'on
va regarder on va regarder les choses
toute façon c'est pas maintenant qu'on
va pouvoir faire laurent berger a sifflé
la fin du débat si je puis dire alors
que il ya quelques semaines le
gouvernement a dit bleu tiens on va
regarder en retraite et la cfdt a dit
attendez ce que vous croyez que c'est
maintenant qu'on va commencer à faire
une réforme des retraites donc c'est un
sujet permanent depuis plusieurs années
on sait qu'il faut prendre des décisions
ben malheureusement c'est pas maintenant
qu'on va les prendre un mot sur la crise
sanitaire
social et sur l'obligation vaccinale
et l'obligation vaccinale sur le
principe ça paraît séduisant mais nous
ne voterons pas pourquoi parce qu'on
voit pas comment on peut l'appliquer
vois pas comment on peut l'appliquer
vous n'allez pas envoyer les policiers
chez les gens
pour les obliger à se vacciner
d'ailleurs on n'a jamais vu un
gouvernement qui pouvait obliger les
gens à se soigner si vous allez chez le
médecin et que vous ne suivez pas ces
prescriptions
sa salle et ses désirs aux vaccins
obligatoires le vaccin contre mais je
pense que
mes collègues socialistes ils voulaient
éviter de parler du passé ni terre donc
c'est commode de dire bon bah écoutez il
ya qu à vacciner tout le monde sauf
qu'une fois qu'on a dit ça
je vois pas très bien comment on peut
l'appliquer regardez ce qui se passe en
polynésie c'est intéressant le
gouvernement local polynésien a décidé
l'obligation vaccinale est bien et la
majorité qui est en train de se déchirer
ils n'arrivent pas à l'appliquer et la
majorité implose donc ça veut dire
qu'ils n'ont pas la vaccination
obligatoire on maintient le pass
sanitaires sur le cas quand
jusque
là possibilité si jusqu'à l'été nous
nous considérons vous le savez qu'au
sénat en particulier que il faut que le
gouvernement revienne
s'expliquer devant le parlement le
problème nous avons voté le pass and i
ter la difficulté c'est que le
gouvernement considère qu' il faut pas
ennuyer le parlement alors si vous voyez
pas d'inconvénient pour la sortie de
l'urgence sanitaire on va faire ça
jusqu'en décembre 22
bon à ce moment là à quoi sert le
parlement ce serait quoi là-bas des
séances vous en fin février mars avant
qu'on rentre dans l'élection
présidentielle ce que craint le
gouvernement sait que ce sera en pleine
campagne électorale et que et la seconde
le parlement même en campagne électorale
il fonctionne
écoutez on peut pas
voter un blanc-seing jusqu'en décembre
22 pour la fin de l'urgence sanitaire et
jusqu'à la fin juillet pour le pass
sanitaires
il ya des possibilités d'aller plus loin
mais il faut que le gouvernement vienne
s'expliquer sur les raisons pour
lesquelles ils souhaitent le faire donc
jusqu'en février fin février ça paraît
une bonne date après si c'est nécessaire
on continuera puisqu'on parle de ce
qu'il s'est passé au sénat il hier
vous êtes à l'origine avec bruno
retailleau proposition de résolution en
faveur de la lutte contre toutes les
formes d'antisémitisme
le texte a été voté au sénat avec le
soutien du gouvernement d'ailleurs au
delà de l'importance du symbole qu'on
comprend bien qu est ce que ça va
changer ce texte je crois que c'est
c'est pas seulement symbolique c'était
dans cette période vous voyez bien dans
les débats quotidiens on entend des
propos
révisionnistes on nous dit vous saviez
peut-être pas mais monsieur pétain
c'était un grand protecteur des juifs
ont parlé d'un examen
on vous dit les enfants assassinés dans
la cour de l'école à toulouse
bah oui ça y sont enterrés en israël
donc c'est pas une affaire française
quand on entend des propos comme ceux-là
on a froid dans le dos
je vais pas jusqu'à l'antisémitisme mais
je veux dire il est important de
rappeler un certain nombre de valeurs et
de dire ce qu'est l'antisémitisme
il faut préciser les choses ne serait ce
que pour les magistrats pour les
policiers pour tous ceux qui doivent
dénoncer et constaté l'antisémitisme
donc je crois que malheureusement comme
l'a dit mon ami roger karoutchi le seul
fait qu'on en parle marque une forme
d'échec et donc il faut poursuivre
inlassablement ce combat parce que
plusieurs décennies après la fin de la
dernière guerre et la shoah on est
obligé encore en 2021 de rappeler la
nécessité de respecter l'autre de
respecter la différence et et de
combattre c'est cette horreur que
l'antisémitisme
vous parliez d'eric zemmour il ne cesse
de grimper dans les sondages un sondage
sort à nouveau aujourd'hui qui le
donnent assez haut est ce que le
phénomène vous inquiète
bah écoute et oui c'est préoccupant il
ya plusieurs choses sont préoccupants le
fait qu'il ait de l'audience ça montre
que malheureusement ça répond à une
attente de certains nombre
d'électeurs peut-être que
je crois que dans le passé récent
depuis et on va dire ces vingt dernières
années les gouvernements successifs
n'ont pas su prendre en compte un
certain nombre de sujets l'immigration
les problèmes sécuritaires ont pris les
vôtres et compris les mouvements de la
droite et du centre tout le monde est
donc
aujourd'hui on voit qu'on arrive à en
période de crise un point de paroxysme
et sont des français qui votent
très droite aujourd'hui tous les
candidats droite par exemple propose en
référendum sur l'immigration donc on a
l'impression que le sujet est traité on
va dire et pourtant non il n'est pas
traité parce que on peut pas évacuer ça
on va faire un référendum je pense à ces
immigrations c'est un sujet compliqué et
ça doit se négocier se discuter au plan
européen c'est pas un seul problème
franco français
quand les gens émigrent il arrive par
l'italie par l'espagne par les pays de
l'est donc c'est un sujet européen
peut toujours faire un référendum
pourquoi pas mais on peut faire un
référendum sur un tas de sujets mais si
on veut trouver des solutions c'est avec
nos partenaires européens qu'il faudra
les trouver c'est pas seulement en parce
que les français vont on voit à peu près
ce que ça peut donner un référendum sur
ce sujet une fois que les français
auront dit oui il faut faire quelque
chose pour on va faire quoi après sur la
question est-ce que vous inquiète pardon
est-ce que vous inquiétez exemple oui
oui il est inquiétant puisque les
sondages apparaître en corse dans les
prochaines heures montre sa progression
et pendant ce temps là à côté ou en face
je vois pas très bien ce qu inquiétant
pourquoi inquiétant pour la droite et le
centre
sont là pourtant sur quoi qui est temps
pour la france parce que je veux dire à
partir du moment où des idées comme
celle qu'il porte
reçoivent autant d'audience et le place
peut-être on verra cet après midi au
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle est-ce qu'il est plus
inquiétant je peux vous demander de
faire une hiérarchie mais que marine le
pen est ce qu'il est plus 10 compliqué
de répondre à eric zemmour aujourd'hui
cas marine le pen objectivement il ya
beaucoup de thèmes similaires
bien sûr paisiblement mais beaucoup
qu'ils ne sont pas beaucoup et ce en
panne visiblement il le fait avec plus
de talent et emportant plus d'espoir
c'est la raison pour laquelle je mets
sur un créneau très étoiles a enfin très
étroit ça commence à prendre de la
proportion parce que il est passé assez
rapidement à pas loin de 15 16 10 parler
des thématiques politiques qui sont sur
un sur un créneau parle d'immigration il
parle d'identité en entend peu parler
d'environnement ou d'économie il l'a vu
récemment
sur sur lci je crois avec certains de
vos confrères donc il est aussi
talentueux malheureusement si je puis
dire dans ces matières là
alors votre parti lui dei a été exclu de
la primaire à droite
c'est une déception pour vous
je pense que c'est une maladresse je
veux dire les républicains choisissent
librement la procédure qui veulent se
donner mais si on veut choisir le
candidat de la droite et du centre il
vaut mieux qu'ils aient du centre donc
ils sont libres de choisir leurs
procédures elles adressent aux calculs
politiques peu importe le résultat c'est
ça c'est qu' il dise on fait ça entre
nous donc ça devient le candidat d'une
partie de la droite donc on voit bien la
difficulté moi j'en rêve autres
votre pas nécessairement
sait rien on va voir vous ne cessez la
question tout l'écran tous les cas si on
attend le 4 décembre c chronique d'une
mort annoncée 1c mortelle randonnée
jédir
pendant que ont fait de la mécanique que
tout le monde essaie de savoir comment
ça va à bidouiller
pendant ce temps là le président de la
république lui continue
distribuer de l'argent
essayer de rassembler autour de lui et
puis d'autres candidats monsieur zemmour
et d'autres avancent donc
adversaires en agissant comme ça oui il
offre un boulevard d'une part et puis
d'autre part on a tendance à oublier que
le candidat c'est le candidat pour
concourir à la présidence de la
république c'est pas pour être chef dlr
ou
organiser je ne sais quelle opération
interne on parle de la présidence de la
république française certes les français
ils attendent de savoir qui va être
candidat pour choisir entre des options
des projets pour savoir ce qu'ils vont
devenir dans l'avenir vous aviez parlé
de retraite on a parlé on a parlé
d'économie je veux dire à un moment
donné il faut savoir de quoi on parle et
là je pense que on est en train de se
fourvoyer et que ça va mal finir donc ça
veut dire que vous ne soutiendrait pas
forcément le candidat qui sera désigné
le 5 décembre ballon puisque ce sera
paul notre
droite
n'ont pour l'instant je redoute rien
puisqu'on sait pas qui ça va être
et qu'on parle pas des projets donc on
verra le moment venu c'est pour ça qu'il
y sera intéressant d'examiner ce que ce
que sera le
la proposition du ou de la candidate
alors ici au sénat vous travailler main
dans la main avec gérard larcher avec
bruno retailleau est ce que cette
histoire peu tendre les relations entre
vous et non en l'état actuel des choses
ça n'a pas que des influences sur le
fonctionnement de la majorité
sénatoriale du merci
j'allais dire que nous continuons à
travailler
indépendamment de ses miasmes extérieur
et on travaille en confiance avec bruno
retailleau sous l'autorité du raz war
chez dernière question sur ce sujet ce
que ça peut vous amener à regarder de
plus près ce qui se passe du côté de la
maison commune qui essaye de construire
la république en marche le modem
oui là aussi c'est je suis passé je suis
pas à construire leur maison c'est
plutôt un ravalement puisque il ya déjà
en marche le modem penser la même chose
je veux bien qu'il paye mes murs mais
j'allais dire non non non d'ailleurs il
ya girondins puisque ils ont fait
l'objet d'une fusion absorption par
edouard philippe à l'insu de leur plein
gré donc
l'histoire de la maison commune ça
regarde la majorité
une partie du centre je pense que compte
tenu de la situation edouard philippe
intéresser beaucoup de gens au centre
droit oui oui chez les hommes comme chez
nous donc le parti qu'il va annoncer
prochainement au havre le week-end
prochain exactement c'est quelque chose
qui peut vous intéresser en tous les cas
on est pas indifférent à ce que fait
edward fils mais relaxé le candidat ait
l'air est jugée trop à droite pour vous
est ce que vous pourriez rejoindre on
n'en est pas là
mais non travaillé ensemble avec les
républicains dans les mairies dans les
départements dans les régions ici au
sénat ça simplement vous me demandez ce
qu'on peut penser d'edouard philippe
c'est vrai que eelv à présenter des
propositions on va regarder ce que ce
que dit edouard philippe
je n'oublie pas quand même qu'il a pris
position pour
emmanuel macron deux questions qui
concernent le sénat pour terminer
d'abord la semaine prochaine vous allez
présenter un texte sur l'implantation
locale des parlementaires pour vous il
faut mettre fin au non cumul des mandats
oui et je suis pas le seul à le penser
et je peux à présent la république
amy déjà des des préoccupations sur ce
sur ce sujet alors je suis pas je suis
pas dupe je pense que ce sera difficile
d'aboutir malheureusement avant la fin
du quinquennat nous on va en discuter
ici dans les jours qui viennent et puis
ça également à l'assemblée nationale
c'est programmé avant la fin de l'année
c'est simplement pour poser le débat
parce que si vous regardez l'exposé des
motifs de la loi 2013 qui a interdit ce
qu'on appelle le cumul des mandats
c'était deux mandats
on disait dans cet exposé des motifs
le parlement a été réformé il va avoir
beaucoup de compétences beaucoup de
travail et donc il faut que les
parlementaires puissent s'impliquer
pleinement dans ce travail moi je suis
désolé le parlement il a deux fois moins
de compétences et deux fois moins
de travail qu'en 2013 et donc les
parlementaires ils sont condamnés à
faire surtout à l'assemblée des
amendements qui n'aboutissent pas donc
on voit bien le le clivage qui s'est
fait entre le terrain et le parlement il
faut pouvoir recréer cette jonction la
dernière question oui cet après midi au
sénat va être discuté d'un texte sur la
réforme de la haute fonction publique et
notamment la réforme de l'ena
pourquoi est ce si important d'en
discuter dans l'hémicycle
c'est un travail qui est à l'initiative
de jean-pierre sueur ancien président de
la commission des lois qui voulait
surtout attirer l'attention et est
montré du doigt une fois de plus
j'allais dire l'absence de parlement
c'est à dire que il ya énormément de
ordonnance à peine 20% ont été ratifiées
et donc c'est dire que pour l'exécutif
le parlement compte pour quantité
négligeable classe et un taxi dépassé
par ordonnance c'est ça mais c'est une
ordonnance on l'a habilité le
gouvernement en 2019 et mais on se
saisit de cette occasion pour dire au
gouvernement écouter ça suffit non
seulement vous faites beaucoup
d'ordonnancé
mais en plus on peut même pas les
ratifier donc la moindre des choses
c'est quand même que le parlement d'un
pays démocratique puisse examiner le
contenu des ordonnances et prendre
position et vérifier si c'est conforme à
l'habilitation merci beaucoup mercer de
marseille
était ce matin christelle en garde la
une de la dépêche pédophiles et le
rapport qui accable l'église c'est à
l'aide de votre journal ce matin merci
beaucoup merci
[Musique]